bill Richardson governor of the state of
New Mexico I come from a bike cultural
background I was born in California but
raised in Mexico City a mother that only
would speak Spanish to me a father who
wouldn't speak to me who would speak
English to me totally bilingual
bicultural background they could shape
me because it's allowed me to respect
other cultures other points of view I
pride myself as a negotiator and
diplomat bringing people together a
healer and and that bilingual background
a mother and a grandmother that gave me
a sense of social justice of Who I am of
trying to help others gave me I believe
the the impetus to eventually run for
public office to be a diplomat to be an
administrator and and now to run for
president as somebody that more than
anything is qualified to bring people
together